[Musique]
porical
mamma mia qui suit up bin laden
[Musique]
2009 va pas qu'est ce qui t'a alim
attachez votre ceinture en dresser votre
siège rangez votre tablette
parce que nous allons pas tardé avec les
rams te plaît pour une fois est ce que
tu peux être plus clair on va dans
l'internet
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bienvenue sur
internet
[Musique]
waouh cool
regarde moi sous ces machins nouveau
miracle j'ai jamais vu de toute ma vie
bienvenue au bar de recherche que puis
je vous aide à trouver aujourd'hui bain
moussant pain de minuit bain de foule ou
non de ville noms de pays non d'athlètes
classique arbalète artichauts j'ai comme
l'impression qu'il essaie de deviner ce
que tu vas dire m'a saisie automatique
est un peu nerveuse ces jours ci attend
l'est trouvez moi un site internet qui
déchire bien des livres aux jeunes et
qu'un seul résultat non dispensés des
personnages de dessins animés
[Musique]
qui va nous mener
salies on se calme et puis je suis une
princesse mozy et quel genre de
princesses et tu ta chevelure est
magique non humains sont magiques
non tu partir dès que les animaux non
content a empoisonné non ensorcelé n'ont
enlevé et séquestré
vous êtes sûr que ça va ou faut que
j'appelle la police est ce que les gens
pensent que tous tes problèmes se sont
réglés parce qu'un homme fort et
puissant a surgi dans ta vie ouais mais
comment ça se fait d'ailleurs c'est une
vraie princesse
[Musique]